hello welcome to game sports coverage of
game of the Year 2015 we're here with
our platform report cards what an
interesting year for nintendo wii u's
doing great a justin hey all it's not
doing bad i mean it's definitely in
third place out of 34 perhaps let's talk
about the good stuff good games decay
man on the wii u this year he's won each
justin god so the nintendo has had a
great overall year even though the
inning layer hasn't been as as strong
but i mean they've had two of the the
best games this year look one per person
so i won't think i'll fix platoon
because I feel like I'll totally be the
bigger champion of that as is so many
hugely ridiculously violent games and I
spent a lot of thanksgiving weekend
catching up on our game of the year
contenders in thinking about like what
what are going to be the best games and
I had to take a break every now and then
from having heads explode and fall out
and watching people die and metal gear
and just so much blood and guts and
destruction to just have some fun in
splatoon where everything's kind of
light and airy and its competitive and
it's a shooter and it's very competent
and it's also just a lot more fun Peter
you said one of the best new IPS that
Nintendo's released in the past couple
years dude absolutely it it has
connected Nintendo to a younger
generation which I think kids pick up on
Mario and stuff like that but splatoon
really speaks to them like it it's sort
of it pulls from these like little
cultures that kids know like through
through you know through media like TV
like you've got like a goth kid you got
a skater kid and all this other stuff
like things Nintendo's never really
represented I don't like that what would
be a one of the best games you think
Nintendo really or came out on Nintendo
platform in 2015 I think the best
probably the best game they put out this
year's Super Mario maker like I it's
everywhere people are making levels and
putting out there it's there's like this
cult it started this like cult around it
and I think that when people think about
what like the best that Nintendo do this
year I think it'll be Mario maker
survive so many games that allow you to
create a little big planet this
different racing games that let you
create tracks but none of them have
captured how quick and easy and simple
and fun as Super Mario maker yeah and it
started
it sort of also fills that like sadistic
desire to create something that will
just screw people over like look at what
Dan did with Patrick and whatnot but see
also they went in like Rhett conned a
lot of stuff from older Mario games like
they have the booze from the old games
redone in like the newer games and like
they redid a lot of the like music from
the newer games for like older like
8-bit look so I know if you look at how
super mario maker has also penetrated
the social networks like you guys have
talked about that a little bit but how
often do we see people who do not own a
wii-u being envious of wii u yes this is
like the first game that I think really
like breaks down those barriers of which
console is better because so many of the
people that are our age now grew up with
Mario to some extent maybe they've moved
on and they don't want to play Yoshi's
woolly world or something like that but
holy [ __ ] a chance to craft like their
own super mario world game like that
that is something that's universal and
really the best argument tone with you
let's write at some of the other great
games to come in on Dan you Peter as
enter played Chronicles X I'm guessing
you're going to say that is one of them
yes that is that is I think obviously
one of them I mean that game has a few
problems but it also is for the Wii U or
any system an amazing open-world game
that has some of the best landscape
design very good creature design and in
really good combat and just the the
longevity of the game there's a wealth
of things to do that are actually fun
and very rewarding and they all kind of
connect themselves in a way where most
games leave these bits and pieces
disconnected so it's a phenomenal game
and it's it's I think a shame it came
out so late in here because it's going
it's going to get lost and for a game
like that to show up on the Wii U it
needs as much room to breathe as
possible and let's talk about missed
opportunities then and mario tennis
Mario Party 10 of course and amiibo
festival and some of the there's a lot
of games that sort of had Nintendo's
you'd imagine would be games with
Nintendo seal of approval I just never
really you know paid off with with wii u
owners well and the problem is a lot of
its coming near the end of the year and
possibly the end of that we use console
lifecycle really next year 2016 is going
to be when the annex comes out and we
have reports coming out that not only is
it going to launch like they're trying
to launch it in a really big way and and
I feel like that's reflected in the
games that we're seeing not only some of
the bigger titles mario tennis
but tri Force heroes like that is a
mainstream Zelda game that is coming
that was their 3ds entry in the Zelda
franchise solace and I felt kind of well
it rushed it was it's fun for what it is
as great music has all the trappings of
Zelda but just not enough it was it's
missing stuff that happy home designer
on I need these are 3ds games with happy
home designer and the amiibo festival on
Wii U or animal crossing games but they
felt like well we need to put out an
animal crossing game right now because
we're going to be moving to other things
really soon and that's felt like the end
of this spell this year for them and we
can't mention Nintendo without talking
about the tragic passing of satira
whatta on July eleventh of this year and
Peter key talked to sort of what do you
think that means four in ten but going
forward like how how important he was to
the success of the company and you know
the change in direction we may see and
edit he's he's not involved obviously I
can only guess but I think someone who
likes to Tory water who has impacted so
many people who don't even know him I
can only imagine how much of an impact
he's had on the people around him that
he worked with day to day and even then
he joined a company and absorbed that
company into his own personality as well
so I think there's a great legacy of
Nintendo that started before him and one
that he helped shape while he was there
so I have some faith that Nintendo will
continue the spirit that he want to sort
of injected into that company and help
grow after he arrived one of the things
that Nintendo has been criticized for
often in the past is it sort of
reluctance to really engage in online in
terms of both communication and
distribution as well and Peter in your
in your report I've read that you were
very happy with what they did in 2015
obviously with in terms of DLC I guess
specifically Mario Kart and Smash Bros
games that you know people love content
for this year they actually have extra
content make a play yeah I mean you look
at a game like mario kart 8 super smash
brothers there's been a lot of DLC and
those games came out last year but we're
still seeing new content every once in a
while especially for smash brothers
those games are very big to begin with
so this type of DLC feels good to me it
doesn't feel like they're nickel and
diming customers for things that are
expected of them out of the gate
splatoon is an excellent example of how
to use free DLC as a way to support a
game
as a service it started off with a
decent amount of stuff to do and it was
a great experience but it felt up just a
little bit light but of course antenna
was always dangly the upcoming stuff
above your head and it was like a week
after launch they started releasing you
stuff there are I think a couple dozen
new weapons already a few new maps new
modes I mean Nintendo has finally
embraced the ability to support a game
after its launched which could lead them
down a path of nickel and diming but I
think their current experiments are
working in such a favorable way for them
and their fans that I think we're going
to see more of this down the road and
this will be great as long as it's
either free for a small game or you know
cheap for a big game and Alexei you were
looting to it with mario maker that's a
game which is its success hat is rested
on digital distribution on yeah on
communication between different players
and I think a Nintendo made a really
good move of a move of good faith when
they removed the lock like they had the
locks where you had to I think play
mario maker for like five minutes every
day there are nine days before you
couldn't unlock the tools and by
removing that I think that shows that
they're really there are more attuned to
what their fans want and what will
ingratiate them with them Justin we also
had a bunch of games pushed back this
year biggie nintendo games that people
are looking forward to obviously we
didn't see Zelda this year at all and
starfox as well push back at 2068 what
do you think that means for Wii U owners
well I think that's another thing that's
kind of showing that these things are
going to be pushed in X I know Peter and
I have had arguments on whether these
games would actually just be coming out
on NX instead or you know maybe it'll be
something like the Gamecube which had
Twilight Princess that came out on
gamecube and wii and Twila princess was
delayed in order to meet both of those
consoles and I kind of thing Zelda is
going to be in that similar frame that
this is going to be something that's on
both consoles starfox was probably
pushed back to just meet quality
standards i mean we saw it at e3 yeah
and it's 80 people taxes well weren't
speaking very hot looks fine it is an
example of Nintendo adhering to a
hardware design decision then they just
can't get over like you do not need the
gamepad to play that game but they
talking to them at e3 they were they
were so steadfast and their their
message that oh no this game could only
be done with
gamepad and I it's it that is the source
of every bit of frustration that anyone
who's played that game is Annette the
only way there you go but they've got a
back a lot on that like a lot of games
now are just a second screen experience
on your wii u because that's what most
people have said they wanted you want to
be able to just set in your couch maybe
somebody else is using the TV and
watching something on that well you get
and just sit and enjoy your game and
that's one of the biggest biggest
strengths of the wii u I feel like yeah
planes in breda blood chronicles
recently that's what I did for the vast
majority of my experience when I was at
home was allowing my girlfriend and
watch TV and you know what like I've I
felt comfortable just the way the motion
you did it's like tucking yourself in a
3d yes it is you've got a couple really
high-powered 3ds and it's nintendo and i
will say give them credit for this the
gamepad got ahead of the remote play
market everybody else yeah steam linked
now like all that stuff like oh you can
send you know like playing away from the
device that you're using is something
that Nintendo has captured and done
really well they don't get enough credit
for that nothing Justin raises a good
point interesting year for Nintendo
interesting year for the wii u perhaps
it's lost as the the forerunner of
Nintendo's consoles thank you so much
all three of you for coming on last
question one word answer one game answer
Justin first of all your favorite game
on the Wii U 2015 in 2015 splatoon
splatoon spittoon for Alexa Peter Super
Mario maker yeah I'm Mario maker for me
as well all right gave it your
discussion should be pretty oh no we're
found beginnings oh really oh yeah you
don't oh not because it's a great of a
game with great I just like that they
put it there Thank you Thank You
Nintendo verb yeah okay Thank You
Nintendo on behalf of Justin I'm here at
gamespot thank you for watching this
video let us know what you think of
Nintendo's 2015 and tell us what your
favorite games that were at on the Wii U
and 3ds were in the comment box below
you